We introduce a new data
structure, the bilateral grid,
which enables real-time,
edge-aware image processing.
2D images are lifted
onto a coarse, 3D grid,
where the z-component
corresponds to intensity.
As a result, points
across a strong edge
are distant in the grid.
We introduce slicing,
an operation that
exploits this
property to extract
a discontinuous, 2D image
from a smooth bilateral grid.
We demonstrate a variety
of real-time, edge-aware
algorithms using
the bilateral grid.
We demonstrate real-time,
bilateral filtering
on a noisy, 12-megapixel input.
The user can explore
the parameter's base
while getting real-time
feedback on the whole image.
We zoom in to show the full
resolution of the image.
Real-time feedback makes
it easy for the user
to fine-tune filter parameters.
We further accelerate the
bilateral filter on video
by sampling a random
10% of the input pixels.
Sub-sampling causes swimming
artifacts, shown on the left.
We eliminate these
artifacts by applying
a temporal exponential
filter, shown on the right.
We demonstrate the real-time
video abstraction technique
by [INAUDIBLE] and
colleagues on HD video.
We adapt real-time
video abstraction
to follow a point of
focus, here controlled
by the mouse pointer.
Elements that are farther
away from the point of focus
are more abstracted.
We first compute the distance
to the point of focus
and cross bilateral filter
it with the input image
to create an adapted
importance map that respects
the edges of the image.
We use this map to composite the
levels of a bilateral pyramid.
The rest of the abstraction
pipeline remains unchanged.
Note that our method
is efficient enough
to compute five bilateral
filters per frame
and allow parameter adjustment
while the video plays.
We transfer the look
of a model photograph
to an input video in real time.
Our result captures the
tonal balance and level
of detail of the model
in the spirit of the work
by Bay and colleagues.
Our method enables on-the-fly
adjustment of parameters
on live, HD video.
Compared to existing
techniques that
require offline
processing, our approach
makes it easy to modify
the level of detail
and adjust the overall
tonal balance of this shot
as it plays.
We demonstrate
bilateral grid painting
by locally modifying
the hue while respecting
strong intensity edges.
The initial mouse
click locks the brush
to an intensity level.
The brush is aware
of edges and does not
paint across intensity
discontinuities.
For instance, the brush does
not affect the white wall
by the door.
Our method runs in
real time on the GPU.
We update the entire 2-megapixel
input on every frame.
We apply the same
technique to locally modify
tone-mapping parameters.
We adjust exposure parameters on
this 15-megapixel HDR panorama.
We paint over the gate to
correct the overexposed region.
Notice how the bars
are unaffected.
Similarly, the
windows are unaffected
while the overexposed
dome is corrected.
Our GPU algorithm updates
the entire 15-megapixel image
on every frame.
We demonstrate
scribble interpolation
using the bilateral grid.
We scribble on the input
image, shown on the left.
The extracted influence
map is shown on the right.
We use the influence map
to drive a color shift.
The white scribbles
cause the cloth
to change from red to blue,
while the black scribbles
protect the candies.
We zoom in to show the
full image resolution.